fijémonos ahora en los tres tipos de
decaimiento radiactivo y vamos a empezar
primero con el decaimiento alfa muy bien
en el decaimiento alfa una partícula
alfa es liberada de un núcleo inestable
así que por ejemplo aquí tenemos nuestro
núcleo inestable que es el uranio 238 y
una partícula alfa tiene la misma
composición que un núcleo de helio y ya
hemos visto los núcleos de helio en
vídeos anteriores verdad en este caso
tenemos dos protones tenemos en los
núcleos de helio tenemos dos protones y
también tenemos dos neutrones cierto
tenemos también dos neutrones ahí
tenemos nuestro núcleo de helio y por
supuesto como tenemos dos protones y dos
neutrones esto tiene una carga dos
positivos así que la carga de una
partícula alfa es dos pues dos positivos
así que para representar una partícula
alfa en nuestra ecuación nuclear como
como una partícula alfa tiene la misma
composición que en un núcleo de helio
simplemente ponemos
el yo aquí verdad y esto tiene dos
cargas positivas verdad mientras que
ponemos un 4 acá arriba porque tiene un
total de 4 núcleo nes muy bien así que
ahora vamos a tratar de descifrar cuál
es el otro producto de nuestra ecuación
nuclear muy bien y sabemos que los
núcleos son conservados verdad así que
si tenemos por ejemplo aquí 238 núcleo
nes del lado izquierdo
necesitamos tener 238 núcleo nes del
lado derecho verdad y tenemos 4 digamos
que aporta el núcleo de helio verdad la
partícula alfa así que necesitamos 234
nucleón es más correcto así que 234 nos
+ 4 nos da 238 verdad y hasta aquí
tenemos que los núcleos son conservados
en esta ecuación ahora fijémonos
hablemos un poquito de la conservación
pero en términos de cargas sabemos
también que la carga debe ser conservada
del lado izquierdo tenemos 92 protones
así que tenemos 92 cargas positivas y
necesitamos 92 cargas positivas también
del lado derecho y ya tenemos 2 cargas
positivas debido a esta partícula alfa
así que necesitamos 90 digamos cargas
positivas extra lo cual nos dice que lo
que sea que haya aquí del lado derecho
en los productos debe tener un número
atómico de 90 así que revisamos
directamente nuestra tabla periódica y
confirmamos que el producto que nos
falta verdad es el torio es el torio y
que lo escribimos como th muy bien así
que tendremos aquí el torio 234 es
nuestro otro producto así que pensemos
qué es lo que ha ocurrido visualmente ok
vamos a empezar con un núcleo de uranio
digamos aquí tenemos nuestro núcleo de
uranio
tenemos el núcleo de uranio y este
núcleo es inestable así que va a liberar
o va a liberar exactamente una partícula
alfa verdad que está compuesta por dos
protones y dos neutrones lo que nos
resta después de que libera esa
partícula alfa es un núcleo de torio que
hemos visto aquí verdad torio 234 así
que esta es una representación visual de
qué es lo que está ocurriendo en nuestra
ecuación nuclear ahora chequeamos qué es
lo que ocurre con el decaimiento de está
muy bien pensemos ahora en el
decaimiento beta y en el decaimiento
beta lo que ocurre es que un link un
electrón es lo que se libera del núcleo
y hemos visto en vídeo en el vídeo
anterior que puede representar el
electrón digamos debido a que tiene una
carga negativa podemos ponerlo
justamente como una carga negativa acá
abajo y el electrón no es ni un protón
ni un neutrón es decir podemos escribir
que tiene un cero verdad
núcleo nes en esta partícula que es un
electrón así que tenemos este electrón y
un electrón que es liberado del núcleo
se le conoce como una partícula beta muy
bien así que esto simplemente podemos
pensarlo como una partícula beta
justamente con una carga menos 1 y en
realidad le ponemos el 0 porque no es un
núcleo en verdad si una partícula beta
es liberada de un núcleo de torio 234
entonces por ejemplo estamos empezando
con torio 234 entonces este núcleo
libera una partícula beta vamos a
ponerlo de este lado de la ecuación
verdad libera una partícula beta nos
preguntamos qué otra cosa se produce del
lado derecho verdad que otra cosa
tenemos que hacer bueno nuevamente
tenemos que fijarnos en el número de
núcleos es verdad y ese tiene que
conservarse así que pensemos que del
lado izquierdo tenemos 234 núcleo nes y
necesitamos 234 del lado derecho verdad
pero aquí tenemos 0
la partícula beta no tiene núcleo nes
así que necesitaremos 234 en lo que sea
que tengamos que poner aquí y nuevamente
tenemos que pensar qué ocurre con la
carga verdad así que tenemos una carga
de 90 positivo verdad del lado izquierdo
tenemos 90 protones y del lado derecho
necesitamos exactamente la misma carga
total verdad así que esto nos da una
carga menos 1 lo cual nos nos dice que
necesitamos colocar aquí una carga de 91
déjenme ponerlo bien necesitamos una
carga de 91 positivo verdad es decir eso
nos indica que lo que sea que haya que
poner aquí debe tener un número atómico
de 91 si nos fijamos ahora en la tabla
periódica encontramos que el elemento
que tiene un número atómico de 91 es el
protector verdad protectivo y lo
escribimos como
y con esto ya tenemos completa nuestra
ecuación nuclear ahora bien pensemos qué
es lo que está ocurriendo en el
decaimiento beta así que vamos a entrar
con un poquito más de detalle ya hemos
hablado un más o menos del número de
protones verdad en este caso dijimos que
tenemos 90 protones del lado izquierdo
entonces preguntémonos ahora cuántos
neutrones tenemos del lado izquierdo
bueno eso simplemente lo calculamos como
234 menos 90 verdad y 234 menos 90 nos
da un total de 144 neutrones muy bien
del lado izquierdo tenemos un total de
144 neutrones ahora pensemos que ocurre
del lado derecho bueno en el lado
derecho sólo consideramos el prot
actinio cierto y podemos calcular el
número de neutrones simplemente restamos
91 a 234 y eso nos da un total de 143
neutrones así que en resumen fuimos de
144 neutro
143 neutrones del lado derecho verdad y
si fijamos si nos fijamos ahora en el
número de protones fuimos de 90 protones
del lado izquierdo a 91 protones del
lado derecho así que hemos perdido un
neutrón y hemos ganado un protón o
podríamos pensar que este neutrón se
convirtió en un protón y esa es una
forma super simplificada de pensar que
es lo que ocurrió así que vamos a
escribirlo bien vamos a pensar esto que
teníamos un neutrón verdad que tiene una
carga cero pero es un núcleo en verdad
entonces escribimos estos números del
lado izquierdo y esto se convierte
digamos en un protón verdad que es un
núcleo y tiene una carga positiva así
que si pensamos de que otra cosa está
hecha este neutrón simplemente seguimos
la misma regla de donde la conservación
de los núcleos es y de la conservación
de la carga muy bien entonces si
pensamos en los núcleos es aquí tenemos
del lado izquierdo un núcleo
y del lado derecho ya tenemos un núcleo
lo que sea que tengamos que agregar ya
no será un núcleo en verdad entonces
ponemos un
ahora bien si nos fijamos en la carga
tenemos una carga cero del lado
izquierdo y del lado derecho tenemos una
carga positiva entonces lo que sea que
tengamos que agregar debe ser una carga
negativa verdad ponemos una carga
negativa y esto por supuesto representa
a un electrón verdad esto representa a
un electrón como lo hemos visto de este
lado y por supuesto este es el electrón
verdad este es el electrón que se libera
del núcleo es justo este electrón el que
se libera del núcleo es decir esta es
nuestra partículas beta ok y por
supuesto también podríamos pensar que
hay otras cosas que se producen en
realidad aquí se produce también un anti
neutrino que lo vamos a denotar de esta
forma también se produce un anti
neutrino y bueno eso en realidad no es
parte de este vídeo así que vamos a
ignorarlo por ahora pero un neutrón en
realidad se convierte en un protón
verdad y también estamos obteniendo una
partícula beta que se libera
y este proceso de hecho está gobernado
por la fuerza nuclear débil la
interacción débil así que como puedes
darte cuenta hay un montón de cosas que
están ocurriendo en el núcleo y que no
vamos a adentrarnos más en este vídeo la
cuestión importante es que seamos
capaces de encontrar una ecuación
nuclear verdad porque seamos capaces de
reconocerla como un decaimiento de tipo
b está muy bien y también que seamos
capaces de escribir todo lo que hay en
este en esta ecuación nuclear ahora
hagamos otro tipo distinto de
decaimiento fijémonos en el decaimiento
gamma muy bien en el decaimiento gamma
lo que se libera son rayos gamma y un
rayo gamma en realidad no tiene ni carga
ni masa ok entonces un rayo gamma no
tiene carga y no tiene masa de hecho es
muy parecido digamos a lo que es la
energía verdad es sí que si pensamos de
esa forma y estos son problemas de
decaimiento muy muy sencillos muy
fáciles así que vamos a empezar con él
lección 99 m y la m en realidad aquí se
refiere a que es meta estable muy bien
es meta estable lo que significa que su
núcleo su núcleo está en un estado
excitado muy bien está en un estado
excitado
es decir que tiene mucha más energía
verdad y la va a acceder digamos como
rayos gamma así que vamos a continuar y
vamos a dibujar nuestro rayo gamma aquí
verdad tendremos nuestro el rayo gamma
que no tiene carga ni tiene masa y como
estamos digamos lidiando simplemente con
ceros verdad sólo tenemos ceros en
realidad no afecta a nuestros números
así que si empezamos con 99 nucleón es
del lado izquierdo vamos a tener 99
nucleón es del lado derecho y si
empezamos con una carga positiva de 43
entonces vamos a tener una carga
positiva de 43 del lado derecho
es decir si nos fijamos en la tabla
periódica justo coincide con el tecnecio
verdad aquí vamos a tener tecnecio
nuevamente sólo que éste tecnecio ya no
se encuentra en un estado excitado sino
que ahora se encuentra en su estado
fundamental muy bien ya no se encuentra
en un estado excitado verdad y lo que
ocurre es que libera energía en forma de
rayos gamma
como lo hemos visto en este ejemplo así
que el tecnecio 99 m de hecho se utiliza
en varias aplicaciones médicas por
ejemplo de procedimientos de imagen y
diagnóstico y eso se debe a que tenemos
varias formas de medir la radiación
gamma así que realmente esto es muy útil
en medicina